there had to be a lot of fear in just
yeah mhm approaching a microphone with
especially for me because I feel like I
was not as I I the change that I made
was very important to me and I
absolutely believed it but it's not the
type of thing that I wanted to all of a
sudden have to defend publicly like I
just I wasn't interested in that like
the way that Rhett likes to talk about
those things is I that just I didn't
want to I didn't want to sign up for
that I did not want to I didn't want to
start arguing with anybody you know and
I really didn't want to ruffle feathers
but
it for me it what put me over the edge
was inclusivity versus
exclusivity and judgment and inclusion
like I really wanted like I was in I was
a loving inclusive person that wasn't
excluding somebody based on their any
type of orientation you know right and
was that which is a dichotomy toward the
teachings of
exactly we have all you know we have all
these fans who come from all walks of
life all different perspectives yeah
some people who you know are
Conservative Christian people but a lot
of people who are not and I think that
our philosophy of inclusivity and
accepting people and encouraging people
to accept themselves versus encouraging
them to adhere to sort of a stone AG
moral
philosophy that is something that that
philosophy has been incredibly harmful
to a lot of people and to a lot of
people who call themselves mythical
beasts you know our fans right so I
think we were like well listen we first
of all we don't want you guys to think
that we stand with that that's not who
we are right that that's what put me
over the edge was I did you know I
didn't want to alienate and I and be
presumed to be judging fans that I cared
about and that I was connecting with and
that I was hearing their stories and my
heart was going out to them and I was
and so I I didn't want them to think the
exact opposite of what I felt about them
as people um so I got more interested
in sharing my truth I guess you would
call it no but it's this is a really
interesting wonderful conversation which
kind of opens us up to not only what you
believe or don't believe but who you are
as human beings and the key is having
respect for absolutely everyone for
Humanity for thought for the pursuit of
the truth you know and not being
closed-minded because and and not that
faith is closed-minded but I think we
are uh developing we're always
developing and and uh humanity is very
comfortable always in stopping the
development if you're comfortable where
you
are most people don't want to learn more
don't want to hear more don't want to
see more don't want to experience more
they just want to hang on to what they
have and we all live in this bubble and
few people are like you guys where
you're kind of like you gotta be open
you gotta be well listen let me tell you
on this side of it it's it's a lot
better as someone who lived within the
confines of that system and someone
who's who is uh more just a you you know
humanitarian humanist at this point um
yeah it's easier because I mean there
were there were years of I I have to F I
have to find a way
to love gay people but not but just but
Jud but not really not really accept
them or their partner
whatever more so than that for me it I
had because you know if you're a
Christian and especially if you're
Evangelical Christian the Mandate is the
Great Commission Jesus telling people to
go and share the gospel right you're
supposed to bring people into the
fold what that does is it sets up this
Dynamic with every single interaction
that you have with a person there's a
burden that you need to tell them this
thing and that the dynamic in your mind
is that I have a truth I possess the
right answers I possess the truth and
there needs to be an exchange of right
TR truth to them that they don't have it
that Dynamic is toxic it is debilitating
it changes every interaction that you
have have with somebody I enjoy living
life so much more now where I get to
talk to somebody and I'm like what am I
going to learn from this person not what
can I teach this person how can I tell
this person that what I believe is right
well like well let's see what I here's
another person with another specific
experience from a different place in the
world
they've got a certain perspective I have
a I have a lot more personal
satisfaction out of getting their
perspective and being like well how does
that impact my perspective versus
carrying around this book of truth that
you have to shove down people's throats
in every opportunity that you get even
if you're doing it in love it's the
dynamic is that you're right and they're
wrong and that you got to settle
[Music]
it night